aujourd'hui,
nous étions préoccupés par le témoignage
médical le matin,
un expert médical a donné des preuves
et dans l'après-midi,
un psychiatre a de nouveau témoigné
plus tard dans l'après-midi, le juge
nous a préparés pour la guillotine de l'
affaire en
disant que les
conclusions finales doivent être faites
lundi prochain, cela a été un choc pour
tout le monde car la
défense avait demandé une prolongation
d'un mois pour préparer les conclusions finales
afin qu'ils se disputent à nouveau demain
mais pour le moment, il est clair que le
magistrat [de la musique] veut guillotiner l'affaire de
manière générale  dans l'ensemble, il s'agit
clairement pour moi de toute façon d'une fraude contre le
tribunal
et lentement, il semble venir
que le magistrat ou le juge en
charge ne
soit euh pas sympathique
à la situation de Julian
ou en fait à aucune des circonstances
entourant une
application extraterritoriale de presse libre de presse libre
de  les lois des états-unis
la compétence
universelle des droits de l'homme universels l'
une des grandes époques faisant des
lois universelles t  sous lequel nous avons fonctionné
jusqu'en 2001,
vous